the centerpiece of relations between the
European Union and the United States is
the transatlantic trade and investment
partnership or TTIP said to be the
biggest bilateral trade pact in the
world the Accord launched a year ago and
designed to drive growth and jobs could
boost the EU economy by 120 billion
euros annually and the US economy by 90
billion euros according to some
estimates but its conclusion hopefully
in the next few years would also give
impetus to world trade talks which have
been at a virtual standstill for several
years the aim of the T tip is to remove
trade barriers in a wide range of
economic sectors to make it easier to
buy and sell goods and services between
the EU and the United States
transatlantic trade totals around 2
billion euros each day and every barrier
lifted could mean big savings the
negotiations focus on three broad themes
market access regulatory issues and
non-tariff barriers and the rules under
which the trade pact would operate on
top of cutting tariffs the EU and the
u.s. want to tackle barriers behind the
customs border like differences in
technical regulations standards and
approval procedures which cost time and
money for example when a car is approved
as safe in the EU it has to undergo a
new approval procedure in the u.s. even
though the safety standards are similar
the TTIP negotiations will also look at
opening markets in services investment
and public procurement